ébranlait le monde du tennis la
championne se retirait du tournoi de
Roland-Garros en évoquant sa santé
mentale fragile un retrait inattendu qui
révélé un sujet tabou celui des troubles
psychologiques chez les athlètes
un an plus tard la question est toujours
d'actualité pendant cette conférence en
marge de l'Omnium Banque Nationale des
athlètes discutent d'équité des genres
et de santé mentale après cette
véritable prise de conscience dans le
monde du sport
la légende du tennis Billie Jean King
l'ancienne numéro 1 a remporté un total
de 39 titres du Grand Chelem en carrière
elle est aussi connue pour son
militantisme en faveur du sport féminin
en 1973 Billy battait l'ancien numéro 1
masculin bobbyrings lors d'un match
événement surnommé la bataille des sexes
[Musique]
pendant son allocution Billie Jean King
a parlé de sa propre santé mentale
sur le cours les questions sur la santé
mentale continue aussi de rebondir
notamment pour bien cadrer ce coup de
retour à Toronto elle qui a pris une
pause après avoir remporté le US Open en
Fernandez aussi veut prioriser sa santé
mentale
Simon tellement je peux être fort dans
les moments dans des moments difficiles
le corps va pouvoir suivre un peu plus
facilement alors j'ai pas besoin de me
battre contre moi-même c'est que je
trouve qu'il donne l'exemple de plus en
plus ces questions de santé mentale
préoccupent les organisations sportives
Marie-France Mercier évolue dans le
monde du tennis depuis presque 20 ans
elle aussi constate une réelle prise de
conscience que ça a toujours été un peu
présent la différence c'est que l'on le
dit avoir autre alors et on le dit à
voix haute parce que les gens sont prêts
à passer à l'action
et ce n'est pas que le tennis olympienne
Stéphanie Labbé a remporté l'or avec
l'équipe canadienne de soccer à Tokyo
inspiré par Naomi Osaka et Simone bells
elle s'est aussi confiée sur ses
épisodes de dépression une façon
dit-elle d'inspirer d'autres athlètes
alors que de plus en plus d'athlètes
sont prêts à montrer l'envers de la
médaille la pression qui augmente avec
l'exigence de toujours performer ici au
Canada Toronto